- Magic to me is the feeling
that you get Christmas Eve
when Santa Claus comes to your
home and delivers presents.
- Botania.
The smile on children's
faces when the rabbit
suddenly appears, they know that's magic.
- It's my passion, it's my
hobby, it's my vocation.
It's everything to me.
- Welcome to Colon, Michigan.
- The magic capital of the world.
- I am John Sterlini, the owner
of Sterlini Magic Manufacturing.
- My name is Rick Fisher,
I'm the president and CEO
of the Fab Magic company.
- I am Greg Bordner,
and I am the president
of Abbott's Magic.
I brought a good book with
me, it's called the Bible.
Sometimes there's some
really cool parts in here.
There's really some fire and brimstone.
There are three magic
shops in Colon, Michigan
and we're about three blocks apart.
- Directly next to me is Fab Magic
and Abbott's Magic is
located one block west of us.
- [Greg] There's a lot of
little things here in Colon.
There are top hats in the street
with flowers blooming in them.
- We have one pizza parlor.
We have two gas stations.
- We only have one blinking light.
- [John] We have a
magician's walk of fame.
- It's kinda like our very
own Hollywood walk of fame.
Our high school mascot
is the Fighting Magi.
- [Greg] There's the Magic City Hardware,
there's Illusions Hair Care.
- And we have three magic shops all
in a town of 1,200 people.
I'll share this with you,
if Colon was any smaller
they'd call it semicolon.
Bad joke.
Yes bad joke.
- Abbott's Magic began
doing the magic convention
80-some years ago.
We've had thousands of
magicians from around the world
that gather here to learn,
to share their knowledge of magic.
- When you perform a magic
trick and a little kid smiles,
and he goes "wow,” and you
can see the magic in his face,
that's really the best part.
- For that 15, 20 minutes,
hour, you hopefully took
that person from this world to this world.
- I always said to my
parents even as a young kid,
"I'm gonna move up here one of these days
"and I'm gonna own a magic shop".
- [Voiceover] So dreams do come true.
- They do come true.